sie riskieren alles Leib und Leben auf
dem gefährlichen Weg über den Ärmelkanal
Flüchtlinge aus aller Welt die nach
Großbritannien wollen in ein Land das
sie nicht will
die britische Regierung kämpft
entschlossen gegen die die es bis zur
britischen Küste schaffen
hier will sie Flüchtlinge sofort
festnehmen und in ein einzelnes Land
ausweisen ins ostafrikanische Ruanda
[Musik]
den radikalen abschiebeplan verfolgen
alle der zuletzt häufig ausgewechselten
konservativen Premierminister ihr
Vorsatz die geflüchteten und ihre
Schlepper von einer Flucht nach England
abschrecken unsere neue Partnerschaft
für Migration und wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung bedeutet dass jeder der
illegal in das Vereinigte Königreich
kommt nach Ruanda abgeschoben werden
kann wir müssen die Menschen Schmuggler
davon abhalten Menschen ins Vereinigte
Königreich zu bringen und das Problem
illegale Migration insgesamt lösen
wir werden neue Gesetze machen um die
kleinen Boote zu stoppen sicherstellen
dass jeder der illegal hierher kommt
festgenommen und schleunigst abgeschoben
wird
[Musik]
Großbritanniens Abkommen mit Ruanda
unterschreibt die britische
Innenministerin Suela man nur in Ruanda
könnten geflüchtete aus aller Welt dann
einen Asylantrag stellen und nie wieder
ins Vereinigte Königreich einreisen
46.000 kamen im vergangenen Jahr über
den Kanal nach Großbritannien das Land
und seine konservative Regierung kämpfen
jetzt damit als der größten brexit
Versprechen einzulösen weniger
Flüchtlinge
der Plan der ist Flüchtling nach
Großbritannien kommt soll auf direktem
Weg weiter ins ostafrikanische Ruanda
geflogen werden und zuvor festgesetzt in
flüchtlingsunterkünften hier sitzen und
warten Sie und das oft für lange Zeit
die Reise vom Vereinigten Königreich bis
nach Ruanda
6.600 km
Ibrahim Flow aus Syrien nach
Großbritannien er will nicht erkannt
werden
nachdem ich eine solch gefährliche Reise
überstanden habe wollen sie mich in ein
unsicheres Land schicken von dem ich
nichts weiß ich habe null Ahnung von
Ruanda ich weiß nur dass es nicht sicher
ist und sehr gefährlich werden kann
Ibrahim saß bereits an Bord dieses
abschiebefluges im Juni 2022 wartet dass
die Reise ihn von seiner Frau und seinem
Kind trennt die bereits länger in London
leben und ohne ihn gekommen waren
wenn sie mich nach Ruanda schicken werde
ich wiederkommen bis ich bei meiner
Familie bin wird mich nichts aufhalten
ich bin bereit dafür zu sterben
doch der erste Versuch der Briten
Migranten nach Ruanda zu fliegen
scheitert der Europäische Gerichtshof
für Menschenrechte schreitet ein Ibrahim
darf erstmal wieder aussteigen
[Musik]
mit den Partnern in Ruanda bringt die
britische Regierung ihr ehrgeiziges
Projekt dennoch voran
längst werden hier die Unterkünfte
gebaut die britische Innenministerin auf
Baustellen Besuch hier sollen in Zukunft
die abgeschobenen wohl
umgerechnet 160 Millionen Euro hat die
britische Regierung bereits an Ruanda
gezahlt
jede einzelne Abschiebung würde den
britischen Steuerzahler rund 197.000
Euro kosten teurer noch als die Menschen
in Großbritannien unterzubringen räumt
das Innenministerium ein
als die Ministerin zurück ist zu Hause
die entschlossene Botschaft an die
Versammlung konservativer Parteifreunde
[Applaus]
wer das Vereinigte Königreich
vorsätzlich illegal betritt und aus
einem sicheren Land kommt wird
schleunigst in seiner Heimat
zurückgeschickt oder nach Ruanda
geflogen
unter konservativen fühlt sich die
Lösung gut an die Flüchtlinge Richtung
Afrika loszuwerden
[Applaus]
im Parlament hingegen kämpft die
Regierung mit dem politischen Gegner ein
großes blame Game entlang ideologischer
Gräben brexit tears gegen brexit-gegner
die Boote zu stoppen das ist nicht nur
meine Priorität es ist die Priorität des
Volkes die Position des leberführers ist
klar er will den Ruanda Deal abräumen er
hat gegen Maßnahmen gestimmt
ausländische Kriminelle abzuschieben und
er argumentiert sogar gegen
abschiebeflüge
damit ist er einfach ein weiterer linker
Jurist der uns im Weg steht
Tories lassen sich nicht abbringen von
ihrem Traum ich würde es großartig
finden wenn auf der Titelseite des
telekraft ein Flugzeug nach Ruanda
abhebt das ist mein Traum davon bin ich
besessen wann wird es soweit sein das
müssen sie die Gerichte Fragen
außerhalb der politischen Blase
investmenster polarisiert der
ruanda-plan auch dafür ist laut Umfragen
nur knapp die Hälfte die anderen halten
die afrika-flüge für eine verwerfliche
Idee
unmoralische ruanda-politik eine Schande
fürs Königreich so Druck des Details
nun müssen Gerichte entscheiden über
Klagen der Asylsuchenden die nach Ruanda
gezwungen werden könnten doch vorerst
scheitert die Regierung an den Richtern
die halten Abschiebung nach Ruanda für
rechtswidrig das Land sei nicht sicher
und die Verwaltung dort überfordert die
Asylverfahren durchzuführen es dürfte
wohl zu einer weiteren Runde vor einem
Berufungsgericht kommen denn die
tori-regierung gibt nicht auf doch für
Menschenrechtsanwälte ist das Vorhaben
ein Desaster von internationalem Format
dies Politik diese Politik dieser Ruanda
Cash für Menschen Plan wie wir ihn
nennen hört die Flüchtlingskonvention
aus die es Menschen ermöglichen soll
dahin zu gehen wo sicher ist und sie in
jedem Fall asylsuchen können bei ihrer
Ankunft stattdessen versucht diese
Regierung es für unrechtmäßig zu
erklären dass Menschen das tun und setzt
sie durch die Ausweisung einem Risiko
aus Hannover
nicht nur in Großbritannien stellt sich
die Opposition auf auch in ruanders
Hauptstadt Kigali gibt es Gegner des
Deals auch wenn noch unklar ist wie
viele die Briten hierher wirklich
abschieben könnten in sich entwickelnden
Ruanda gebe es schon jetzt nicht genug
Jobs und natürliche Ressourcen für alle
befürchtet Frank habineser der
Vorsitzende der Grünen Oppositionspartei
Ruanda und Großbritannien haben beide
die un-flüchtlingskonvention
unterzeichnet sie haben beide die
pflichtflüchtlinge aufzunehmen wir
glauben also dass es nicht unsere
Pflicht ist die Menschen aufzunehmen die
ins vereinte Königreich geflohen sind
[Musik]
in Großbritannien müssen jetzt mehr und
mehr Flüchtlinge aus den auffangzentren
ausziehen weil es zu eng wird sie werden
in Hotels untergebracht wie hier in
Liverpool denn im Königreich gibt es
nicht genug Unterkünfte doch manche
Bürger bringt das noch mehr auf gegen
die geflüchteten Menschen in
Wohngegenden in denen sie untergebracht
werden kommt es schon mal zu brennendem
Protest vor flüchtlingsunterkünften
und im Parlament wieder
Schuldzuweisungen die Schatten
Innenministerin der leberpartei gegen
die amtierende Innenministerin
es gibt nur noch halb so viele
Verurteilungen von Schleppern das
Innenministerium schafft es nur über 40%
der Asylgesuche zu entscheiden der
Rückstand und die Hotelkosten wachsen
immer weiter das ganze Asylsystem ist
kaputt und die Konservativen haben es
zerstört
[Applaus]
er ist einer von denen die feststecken
in der Warteschlange er weiß nicht ob er
irgendwann nach Ruanda fliegen muss Rafi
den wir nicht zeigen ist aus Iran
geflüchtet und hat es in einem Boot über
den englischen Kanal geschafft
viele hier leben seit fast drei Jahren
in diesem Hotel nichts passiert mit ihm
häufig haben sie Depressionen weil sie
so darunter leiden dass sie wie ich hier
sitzen
Anwalt hält das alles für uns zumutbar
die ganze große Aussichtslosigkeit
es gibt keine sicheren legalen Routen es
wird immer schlimmer dass die
Asylsuchenden die nach Großbritannien
kommen kriminalisiert und bestraft
werden
in Iran fühlt sich Rafi verfolgt nach
Ruanda will er keinesfalls
ich möchte lieber sterben als dort
hinzugehen weil es wo sie uns
hinschicken wollen kein Leben gibt für
mich die Menschen dort sind arm haben
selbst nichts so wird es uns auch gehen
selbst in Europa sucht der britische
Premierminister nach Verbündeten um die
Flüchtenden schon auf der französischen
Seite des Kanals aufzuhalten Präsident
macron soll helfen
so naag ist unter Druck das hinzukriegen
die Boote stoppen das hat er als eines
der wichtigsten Ziele seiner Regierung
ausgerufen
wir werden ein neues arrestzentrum in
Nordfrankreich bauen eine neue
Kommandozentrale in der zum ersten Mal
Teams beider Länder zusammenarbeiten und
zusätzliche 500 Kräfte für Patrouillen
an der französischen Küste
auch hier wird es teuer für
Großbritannien umgerechnet 667 Millionen
Euro kostet dieser Plan
er soll Menschen daran hindern ein Boot
Richtung England zu besteigen doch die
Flüchtlinge auf der französischen Seite
des Kanals sind fest entschlossen
ja ich gehe rüber nach Großbritannien
das ist mein Ehrgeiz mein Traum
mehr als 11.000 kamen bereits in diesem
Jahr entboten nach England trotz des
britischen abschiebeplans von ihrem
Risiko nach Ruanda abgeschoben zu werden
dürften viele der geflüchteten wohl kaum
etwas wissen Abschreckung das ist die
Methode der Regierung doch dieser Plan
scheint noch nicht aufzugehen
ihre Politik ist nicht umsetzbar wir
werden nicht klein beigeben und das mit
Händen und Füßen bekämpfen
als Ruandas Präsident Kagame im Mai
Downing Street number ten besucht
gegenseitige Bestätigung dass man auf
dem richtigen Weg sei ein Rückschlägen
bei der britischen Asylpolitik zum Trotz
[Musik]
man gebe ein gutes politisches Beispiel
finden die beiden
was der britische Umgang mit Menschen in
Not sagt über das Land dass die
Flüchtlinge einfach nur loswerden will
die Debatte quält Großbritannien und
vereinbar mit der Identität der Briten
finden viele die konservative
Asylpolitik spaltet
und die gewichtige Stimme des
Erzbischofs von Canterbury der auch im
britischen Oberhaus sitzt erinnert
zumindest kurz ans alte Selbstbild der
geschichtsträchtigen Demokratie
es ist moralisch unannehbar und
politisch nicht machbar die ärmsten
Länder mit der Krise allein zu lassen
und unsere internationale Hilfe
einzustellen
ich dränge die Regierung das meiste an
diesem Gesetz zu überdenken dass unsere
Geschichte nicht gerecht wird unserer
moralischen Verantwortung und unseren
politischen und internationalen
Interessen
die Boote kommen weiter die die
Flüchtlinge bringen in eine ungewisse
Zukunft es ist unklar ob die Regierung
Ihr gewünschtes Ziel am Ende erreichen
kann die Menschen abzuschrecken und
Flugzeuge nach Ruanda starten zu lassen
doch die Konservativen Ringen darum mit
allen Mitteln und gegen alle Zweifel
die politische mächtigen die für die
Wahl im kommenden Jahr miese Aussichten
haben riskieren dafür Reputation und
Glaubwürdigkeit Großbritanniens ging es
nach ihnen blieben die Briten auf ihrer
Insel lieber ganz allein
[Musik]